hey this is us divorce shocker et has
confirmed that Justin Hartley has filed
for divorce from wife Rachelle staus
after two years of marriage we met
through sort of like a series of friends
me inquiring about her at a certain
point and then her kind of inquiring
about me at a certain point and then us
putting the pieces together and
realizing that we were inquiring about
each other et has obtained the court
documents interestingly Hartley listed
their date of separation as July 8 2019
though they have been spotted together
several times since here's the couple
just eight days before the filing
appearing happy during a Golden Globes
party on November 14th et even spoke
with them at the Emmys in September tell
me woman and that is a dress and this is
like this what I mean come on give me a
break right what a vision it's
incredible it's incredible the two dated
for three years before getting married
in October 2017 it's kind of cool like
to be able to call her wife that's kind
of neat you know and to be referred to
as husband that's kind of cool we've
chatted with a couple many times
throughout their relationship best thing
about being married so far oh gosh
I like the saying wife they have no
children together and it's unclear if
they have a prenup
[Music]